His words full of hatred that designate our country as the
enemy and our threats are totally revolting and intolerable.
How can we accept without listening that the
anthem of a foreign country attacks France so harshly.
I denounced this decision to the National Assembly and it
earned me many attacks from the other side of the Mediterranean
but also from our own soil which is even more serious and worrying.
But it doesn't matter because I will
never weaken when it comes to defending France
Because yes our country is targeted and I blame the head of state
for not having said anything I also blame him for having
sacrificed our relationship with Morocco to try to please the Algerian power.
At the initiative of erikciotti.
We went with my friend Rachida and Ronan le bleu to
this big country a few weeks ago to meet with politicians.
I want to tell them our will to revive our relations because
for us there will be no Mediterranean policy without Morocco
and the President of the Republic must finally understand this.